[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
good morning
to our newest class of
scholars
welcome to yale
i'm delighted to join your dean dean
cooley and other members of the yale
community
in marking the beginning
of your
graduate studies at yale
you know i was in your position back
in 1981
i came to yale
as a graduate student from stanford i
had worked in the bay area for a year
and when i arrived here
i had a pretty clear understanding of
the work i wanted to do in graduate
school and i'm sure many of you do as
well
but i really had no idea
how much yale would shape my life
both
professionally and personally
i also really couldn't have predicted my
career trajectory but that's another
story
as a graduate student
i knew i wanted to be a clinically
trained social psychologist
to study human emotion and eventually
my goal was to have a research group and
a laboratory
but i never would have thought
that the mentoring i received the
insights the insights i gained
and the relationships i developed
would lead here
in graduate school i didn't foresee what
i that what i learned would one day
help me serve
serve this wonderful university
a beautiful
complex community
of individuals from all
walks of life
ironically although i came here to
conduct research on emotion and that
later led to work on emotional
intelligence
my mentors in the psychology department
led me to study as well
how people process information about
health and how to design messages about
health that motivate people
to protect their health and the health
of others
here we are
the end of a pandemic i hope
and
that experience has come in handy
so each of these lines of work seems so
applicable at the present moment
but it's all more than i really could
imagine at the time i was in graduate
school
well i don't have to tell you
how unpredictable this world of ours can
be
the coven 19 pandemic has reshaped our
lives and our society and
ways that
few of us could imagine
there are many changes we made during
the last two years
that we're going to keep in place we
call them covid keepers
place is permanently changed
coven 19 has
reshaped our lives
alongside this historic public health
crisis
we've also witnessed a a national
reckoning
around racism
we've witnessed the perils of conflict
and political upheaval
we've witnessed the continued impact of
climate change
on our planet
in the midst of this kind of turbulence
we know that the world needs solutions
from the kinds of research and
scholarship you
will be conducting at yale
however because we've seen how quickly
our routines and plans can be upended we
know
that it would be unwise to think we can
completely map out our paths
in life
instead of being weighed down by
uncertainty though
be open to the possibilities ahead
view each unexpected challenge as a
potential to create a change in you and
in the communities
of which you're a part
as you embark on your studies at yale
you will gain knowledge and skills that
are expected of an excellent graduate
education
but you will also have opportunities to
develop
new interests
and explore unplanned avenues of inquiry
along the way
look for those moments
look for those moments because you never
know how significant they will be for
you
for your local community
for your country for the world
all of you
have come here with ideas of what you
want to do but keep your eyes open for
unexpected paths
that may unfold for you
since the beginning of the pandemic i've
been reminded of the importance of being
receptive to
unforeseen possibilities every time
i've seen gale graduate francis collins
speak about efforts to control the
spread of covet
many of you know dr collins
was the acting is the acting science
advisor to president biden he was
formerly the director of the national
institutes of health
and he's one of the country's most
respected physician scientists
and public health authorities
now when he was starting his graduate
studies right here at yale
he was in
physical chemistry
and he said he had no interest in
medicine or biology
in fact he thought biology was chaotic
and unpredictable sorry for those of you
going into biology
like our provost and our dean
that all changed he took a course in
biochemistry it inspired in him a deep
interest in genetics
and that led him to alter his career
paths
that one biochemistry course at yale as
a graduate student became an unexpected
turning point
in his life
he went on to contribute to the
identification of the cystic fibrosis
gene
that led to the development of a therapy
that could help tens of thousands of
people living with this disease
he was also at the helm
of the human genome project which has
given us a detailed knowledge about the
structure and function of our genes
and in recent years he spearheaded
efforts to stop
a pandemic
what unassuming course could change your
views
or set you on a new path in the coming
years
what could it mean
to the world
not all moments of inspiration will
happen inside a library or a classroom
or a laboratory
or a lecture hall
although i hope many will
but that is why i hope you will immerse
yourself fully
in the yell community
i think of recent graduates who often
point to experiences outside of their
departments
that led them in new and fruitful
directions
lucy armantano who received her phd in
psychology last year my department
said that serving as the chair of the
graduate student assembly was her most
meaningful and rewarding experience at
yale
at least one of the most
gsa she said was really formative in her
identity as a graduate student
she said i never really thought of
myself as an advocate or leader until
gsa and then being gsa chair
wasn't the most incredible thing i've
done professionally it was a pinnacle
schwartman came to yale with a special
interest in music pedagogy
he joined the new england conservatory's
faculty after he received his phd here
in music theory
yet it was a peer in his graduate class
here at yale that got him involved in
the yale school of medicine project
designed to promote healthy lives among
young adults through virtual reality
so in addition to his teaching of music
theory andrew now serves as the audio
director of the medical school's play
for real xr lab
crafting a sound environment for virtual
reality games and mobilizing his musical
prowess in support of public health
i think of a student named edgar garcia
whose academic career as he said took
some unexpected turns along the way
he came prepared to study early american
poetics
but then a fellowship at the beineckey
library
changed the focus of his phd work
to 20th century poetics and latinx
literature
edgar said the resources of the beinecke
made 20th century poetics more
materially resonant
and that his english department mentors
and colleagues were fully supportive of
his newfound
academic interests
i think you get the idea
you will find
that some of your most memorable moments
may happen in even more unexpected
places
i was recently reading an article about
patrick geroge he's the governor of the
central bank of kenya
and he received his phd in economics at
yale
in 1993
and he was talking about the valuable
mentorship that he received from faculty
members like james tobin and william
brainard
but he also was reminiscing about
attending the yale harvard football game
in 1987.
it was cold he said
it was the coldest day that i had ever
faced in my life
there was a sub-zero it was sub-zero
with the windchill factor
i don't even remember who won
survival was the only thing on my mind
but survive he did
and he used his yell education to help
foster economic opportunity and improve
the lives of people in kenya
and across the continent of africa
be open be open to the options before
you be curious
about the work and interests of your
peers across departments
you'll find that yale foster is the kind
of environment that encourages you to
pursue
what you came here to do
but also offers unexpected ways for you
to expand
your horizons
if you immerse yourself in the
intellectual social and cultural life of
the university
as a whole
and don't forget
it's also a place you will make
wonderful friends
and find lifelong mentors
i just had lunch two weeks ago
with my graduate school office mate who
sat at a desk next to me for four years
in the basement of kirtland hall in the
psychology department
we've been friends for 40 years
i also met marta my wife
when we were both graduate students
at yale
and in 1986
in may i submitted my dissertation
in june we got married
and in july i started on the faculty
here
so
it was a time of great transition
but it was the beginning of the next
phase of my of my wife my life
also my wife marta why don't you stand
up for a minute and just so people can
see who you are
[Applause]
people think
the new dean of yale college and i are
the shortest people on campus but in
fact marta
is really really
wearing that with great pride
well in the coming years
you will learn you will grow
you will find surprising opportunities
and challenges i guarantee that
but what i can't predict
is what you will do ultimately with your
yale graduate education
with the knowledge with the expertise
with the experience with the wisdom
you will gain
what we do know is that yale graduates
have gone on to lead in business in
science and technology in the arts
and in the humanities
they are leaving their mark
they are realizing yale's vision and
mission
to educate aspiring leaders worldwide
who serve all sectors
of society
it's going to go quickly
before you know it
you will be graduating
and you will take your ideas
and dreams
incubated at yale you will take them
and bring them
to life
in novel ways
i'm counting on you to improve the world
today
and for future generations
i can't wait
to see what you are all
going to accomplish
on behalf of all of my colleagues here
on stage with me
we welcome you
to yale
thank you
and now it is a great pleasure for me to
welcome
you once again by introducing you to
your dean
lynn cooley your dean now in her second
term as the dean of graduate of the
graduate school of arts and sciences
she's a tireless advocate for graduate
students a powerful agent of change in
graduate education here at yale
dean cooley is the cnh long professor of
genetics she's also a professor of cell
biology and of molecular cellular and
developmental biology
and she's the vice provost for
postdoctoral affairs
she was for many years the director of
yale's combined program in the
biological and biomedical sciences
dean cooley earned her ba from
connecticut college
her phd from the university of texas and
she carried out research
with sterling professor dieter saul here
in yale's department of molecular
biophysics and biochemistry
after postdoctoral training at the
carnegie institution of science
she joined the l faculty to study
cellular mechanisms underlying female
and male fertility
she's been recognized as recognized with
a pew scholar award from the pew
charitable trust she's a member of the
connecticut academy for science and
engineering and a fellow of the american
association
for the advancement of science
she served on the board of the genetic
society of america for many years and
she was the president
in 2017.
in the spirit of my
speech just now dean cooley has many
other interests
she's an avid member of the appalachian
mountain club
she's a student of modern dance
she's a devoted mother of two daughters
who are both yale graduates
and it gives me great pleasure to
introduce you
to your dean and one of yale's
outstanding faculty members
lynn cooley
thank you
thank you president salve for the your
remarks and that wonderful introduction
good morning distinguished colleagues
and good morning to you
new master's degree students doctoral
students and visiting students in the
graduate school of arts and sciences
we are thrilled to welcome you as the
newest members of our community
you should be proud of all your hard
work that brought you here today
with deep gratitude and respect
i want to begin by acknowledging the
indigenous peoples and nations
including mohegan
mashintuck at pequot eastern pequot
scotticoach golden hill poguset niantic
and the quinnipiac and other
algonquian-speaking peoples who have
stewarded through generations the lands
and waterways of what is now the state
of connecticut and yale university
we honor the enduring relationship that
exists between these peoples and nations
and this land and recognize that this
relationship is as much a part of our
history
as it is a part of our present and
future
graduate students
you were selected here to be here
because you have proven abilities and
unlimited promise
you are here because our faculty
recognized your intellectual curiosity
and creativity
your academic drive and rigor
your passion for discovery and your
potential for leadership
you are here
because we believe
you can make valuable contributions to
both yale and the world
and we end because we know yale can help
you on your path to intellectual growth
we're delighted you have chosen to join
us
the graduate school is at the very heart
of yale's mission as a university
our mission is to educate graduate
students to seek answers to life's most
challenging questions
as you join us here today you are
setting off on a chapter of your life
that will allow you to explore a field
in depth
master an area of inquiry
and learn to disseminate knowledge
within and beyond the classroom
this year's incoming class in the
graduate school has 535 doctoral
students
and 219 masters students
collectively you represent 54 countries
and 39 states of the united states plus
washington d.c and puerto rico
54 of you are international students
you will be working across the graduate
school's more than 70 departments and
programs
but whatever your area of study may be
proteins or poetry
ecosystems or solar systems
you all share a common motivation
you're driven by the desire to learn
more
by the thrill of discovering new truths
about our world and by the desire to
stretch your imagination and create new
knowledge
so reflecting on the composition of this
class i can tell you yale is fortunate
to gather the best students from across
the globe
which means if you look around you
you come from all walks of life
backgrounds and identities
the graduate school is committed to
creating an environment in which all of
you
can thrive and excel
partly because we value diversity equity
inclusion and belonging as a core
principle of the university
but also
because research shows that groups who
embody these qualities are better
investigators and smarter thinkers
i had my own eye opening experience as a
graduate student many years ago
when i found myself in a laboratory
where i was one of a small minority of
americans surrounded by people from all
over the world
i learned learned things like a few
phrases in german and japanese
but i also learned that our each of our
backgrounds
and experiences meant we could each
contribute in our own ways to the
culture of the lab
my lab mates got a kick out of learning
some phrases in american sign language
from me
i still remember when one of the
post-docs i greatly admired
realized his experiment
had crashed for the day
and instead of being forlorn he grinned
at me across the lab and signed
free day
and left
his reaction showed me that the give and
take of different languages helped
create an atmosphere of trust
in which we could comfortably share
research ideas and anything else no
matter how crazy they seemed
it also showed me it was okay to take
some
free time when you hit a temporary
roadblock
both were valuable lessons to me as a
young person in a new environment
it can be overwhelming to start this new
chapter in your life you're in a new
city for most of you
meeting lots of new people and figuring
out how to navigate the first steps of
graduate school
trust that you belong here
trust that bringing your whole self will
make everything better
trust that you will contribute
positively to the people around you
based on your experiences and
perspectives learn to listen
learn when to listen and when to speak
up to put yourself out there and start
conversations with people you don't know
yet
over the next few days
be intentionable intentional about
meeting new people and be open to
building relationships with them
some of those relationships may lead to
to future collaborations and other may
lead to lifelong friends
or even marriage
the human connections you form be they
personal or
professional will sustain you
these human connections can also help
you when discussing fraught or complex
issues with your peers
yale is committed to the free exchange
of ideas
and it is the foundation upon which the
university exists in its educational
enterprise
yale's official
statement on freedom of expression
commonly referred to as the woodward
report makes the following statement
that i quote
by voluntarily taking up membership in a
university
and thereby asserting a claim to its
rights and privileges
members also acknowledge the existence
of certain obligations upon themselves
and their fellows
above all
every member of the university has an
obligation to permit free expression in
the university
no member has a right to prevent such
expression close quote
questioning questioning your assumptions
about what you currently know will
broaden your understanding of the world
both in the classroom and in your
interactions with those you encounter in
your daily lives
you have made it to graduate school
because you excelled intellectually
but yale is a place that requires you to
be emotionally intelligent as well
you may hear passionate opinions about
campus issues
or issues playing out across the country
and around the world
be willing to listen to a range of views
and develop your own opinions
even if it means agreeing to disagree
from time to time
disagreement does not inhibit growth or
disregard mutual respect we cannot lose
sight of our collective humanity
if you feel a bit unsure about what is
to come
this is absolutely normal
in fact that feeling is the perfect
starting point for what you have come
here to do your time in graduate school
is very much about getting comfortable
with uncertainty
and dwelling at the edge of the unknown
don't think we have a single word for
that state
but we can describe it
as a tolerance for ambi ambiguity
the romantic poet john keats called it
negative
capability or the capacity to thrive in
the midst of uncertainty and doubt
it may sound like an unpleasant state
but keats and others after him
understood negative capability as a
positive prerequisite for discovery and
creativity
one of our aims in the graduate school
is to help you develop the negative
capability you need
to be comfortable when faced with
uncertainty and mystery
to become the scholars and researchers
you
aspire to be
who can push forward the boundaries of
what we know and understand about the
world
that search can truly be disconcerting
and difficult but don't insist on
certainty where there is none
nothing great comes out of being
entirely comfortable all the time
some days will just not go as planned
theories and experiments may not take
you where you expect to go
i have learned this lesson over and over
again in my time as a research scientist
in fact the most exciting days in my lab
are when an unexpected result leads to a
brand new area
most recently
investigating the function of a gene
required for egg development
and fertility in females
has led us to studying brain specific
protein synthesis in a way that wasn't
possible before i never would have
imagined that transition
the network you create and the
departmental home you have joined will
give you the support you need to survive
and thrive in graduate school
you will find that graduate school is
very different from your previous
experiences
you are you are will be much more
responsible for your own education than
you ever have been before your schedules
will be less predictable than they were
in the past
this is not an easy endeavor and it
isn't meant to be one
there will be challenges and obstacles
ahead but trust that you will move
forward
if you start to think you're in it alone
remember
you are surrounded by mentors and
advocates
in the form of faculty members many of
whom are here with me today
staff and peers just look around the
lawn here
the peers that you we find here
along with faculty and staff are are
here to support you and offer advice
when you need it
look to those around you for inspiration
and guidance and you will find it
you're bart about to embark on a
marathon not a sprint
pace yourself be kind to yourself and
others and ask for help when you need it
though obstacles will exist great
solutions to the world's most
challenging problems will emerge from
your time here
as graduate students you hold a special
place in the university landscape at the
intersection of all the research and
teaching teaching happening across
campus
you're not simply here to learn from the
faculty you're here to learn with them
your fresh insights
and persistent curiosity are the
catalysts to new ways of thinking
learning and creating
we are eager to witness and celebrate
all that you will accomplish
and the world will be waiting for you to
come out and share what you've learned
as soon as you're ready
the empathy you develop from being
immersed in a diverse community will
better position you
to offer solutions in ways that promote
peace and dignity for all concerned
you will become better communicators in
order to share your findings with
colleagues in your own field but very
importantly the lay public as well
recent history has shown us that we all
must devote energy toward keeping
helping leaders
make decisions based on fact and insight
i want to echo president salve by
encouraging you to participate fully in
our community in ways that suit your
personal and academic goals best
during your orientation orientation week
you'll learn there are many student
clubs institutes and organizations to
explore
you will undoubtedly be able to find one
or more that match your interest
if you're interested in student advocacy
truly improving the lives of your fellow
graduate students during your time
the graduate student assembly or gsa
works closely with my office
to identify student priorities and
address them as quickly as possible
lucy armantado who president salovey
mentioned was of an incredible leader
during her time leading the gsa
throughout the pandemic my office
collaborated with gsa representatives to
respond to student needs such as
increased stipends enhanced child care
support and improved mental health
resources
we accomplished these things together
through trust
collaboration and honesty
student government works here and i urge
you to participate
as you become immersed in your research
and in our community i also encourage
you to keep your eye on your future
after yale
though this is your first official day
of graduate school it is not too early
to start investigating and planning your
next chapter
visit our office of career strategy for
programs and advice about careers within
and beyond the academy
they provide invaluable guidance
professional development and concrete
plans of action for anyone building a
career
the graduate school also has highly
accomplished and dedicated alumni who
come back to yale to help you
later this year you will be hearing
about the alumni associations
where do i go from yale workshop held
each spring semester
this will give you a chance to see what
our amazing alumni are doing
people who were once sitting
right where you are
today they can inspire your work and
give you ideas for the future
until then tap into our vast alumni
network through the cross campus
platform it's a great way to make
connections with alumni in your fields
of interest who are willing to offer
advice ideas and all the wisdom of
someone who has been there
there are great people
and and they can open your eyes to
opportunities you may not have
considered yet
to close
today is the start of an exciting
journey for all of you graduate students
seize the opportunities to grow
to challenge yourself
to and be sure to celebrate not only
your own successes but those of your
colleagues and friends
yale will have an impact on you but you
will also have an impact on this campus
and after you graduate on all sectors of
society
we welcome you to this community and we
look forward to all that's in store for
you
[Applause]
okay now for a little bit of
entertainment and to demonstrate that
graduate students do have fun sometimes
i am very pleased to welcome the
graduate school's own acapella group the
citations
[Applause]
way down way down in new haven town
lives mr yale old eli hill no one ever
does to come around just because of his
[Music]
he raises an awful brow
you
hear that
[Music]
thank you
and good morning we are the citations
the
oldest the finest the most melodious and
the only graduate and professional
student a cappella group here at yale
we're so excited to be here with you
this morning we have a few selections
starting with a homegrown mashup on the
theme of volcanoes and we hope you enjoy
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's all over now
before it has begun we've already won
we
are wild we are like young volcanoes
wild americana
exotica do you wanna feel a little
beautiful baby
[Music]
[Music]
many
[Music]
fell
days
[Music]
but if you close your eyes
[Music]
almost
[Music]
we were
caught up
make it
[Music]
run easy up
[Music]
we've already won
we
are wild we are like young
[Music]
[Music]
do you want to feel a little beautiful
baby
[Music]
the rubble or our sins
oh
where do we begin
[Music]
darkness
[Music]
and if you close your eyes
does it almost feel like you've been
here before
[Music]
how am i gonna be an optimist about this
if you close your eyes
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
i've heard there was a secret court that
david played and he pleased the lord but
you don't really care for music to you
well it goes like this the fourth the
fifth the minor fall the major
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
well your faith was strong but you
needed proof
you saw her bathing on the roof
her
[Music]
and she cut your hair
and from your lips
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
i used to live alone before
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
maybe there's a god above
but all i've ever learned from love is
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you so much
i want to make a quick plug here that
will be having auditions for all
graduate and professional school
students this september please look us
up if you'd like to be up here next year
if you'd like to join us
we have one more song before we go it's
a classic by queen we hope you enjoy
can
anybody
find me
[Music]
each
[Music]
oh i spent all my years and believe in
you
but i just can't get no relief
on somebody or somebody
can
anybody find me
[Music]
every day of my life
[Music]
till the
tears down from my eye lord somebody or
somebody oh can
anybody find me
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody wants to put me down they say
i'm going crazy
they say i got a lot of water on my
brain
but i've got no common sense
[Applause]
[Music]
he's all right
[Music]
[Applause]
someday i'm gonna be free
[Music]
me
somebody somebody find me somebody find
me somebody to love can anybody
find me
[Music]
find me
[Music]
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
well thank you citations
you are a versatile group this year let
me say that
opening with fight songs and
closing with queen and
a little bit of your own mashup and uh
and leonard cohen in between
so you're singing leonard cohen makes me
feel like i'm not too old for this job
actually
thank you
let's have another hand for the citation
so i hope
that was as inspiring to you as it was
to me and
it is now
my pleasure
to introduce you to sharon coogler gail
gales university chaplain
chaplain coogler joined the yale
community in 2007
bringing with her over two decades of
experience in ministry and higher
education interfaith collaboration and
pastoral and social ministry
over the past 14 years she has
cultivated a chaplaincy that serves the
needs
of the richly diverse religious and
spiritual
spiritual
traditions
of our faculty
students and staff
for our campus community
she facilitates
deeper dialogue
increased access personal growth
creative educational opportunities
and pastoral leadership
chaplain coogler is also a lecturer of
inter-religious engagement and
chaplaincy at the yale divinity school
and so i will turn things over to
chaplain coogler
for the benediction
in his work today is a new day
a piece that is both poem and invitation
to young scholars the 2015 u.s poet
laureate juan philippe herrera wrote
today is a new day
you
are that new day
today you are that new time
now visible
now prepared
now filled with eagerness and hope
you are that hope
the wild-born vista of new horizons
students faculty staff loved ones
you are each and every one part of a
whole new yale
a new circle of scholars and friends
what yale was yesterday is not what it
is today or will be tomorrow because of
you
your questions will emerge and then
bloom
and your fresh intellect will carry us
all to a new discovery
to a new day
as we prepare to take our next steps
into these new discoveries we note our
anxieties
but we also lift up our considerable
abilities
and the remarkable fellowship we will
come to share
in community
let curiosity nourish us
and compassion guide us
as this new creation unfolds
on this day and every day forward may
all that is holy shine upon us
and tenderly bless our every breath
may we go
in shalom
in salam
in shanti
may we go in peace
this is our new day
let us begin